at first you choose a partner based on
appearance and enjoy it until you
realize that your children will be
raised not based on
appearance but based on
values no amount of success can
compensate for failure at
home if people took back the pain they
caused you you'd lose the strength you
gained
the average of five is real if you
really want to know someone look at the
five people they talk to the most and
spend the most time
with your friends problems become your
problems the smaller your Social Circle
the fewer problems you
have once you realize your value you
will be greatly surprised at what you
you used to settle
for when you laugh people laugh with you
and when you cry you cry
alone just because you miss someone
doesn't mean you need them back in your
life missing is a part of getting
over the magic you are looking for is in
the work you're
avoiding
over
trusting
betrayal
masturbation loss of
energy
stress hair loss
overthinking depression saying no
important
Revenge ruining your own life
observing increase in
wisdom
forgiving healing
Letting Go peace of
mind you can always earn money it's not
a big deal your world is not going to
end because you don't have a fixed
income something else will work
out every person has three
faces firstly the one we show to the
world and
strangers secondly
the one we show to family spouses and
close friends and thirdly the one we
show only to
ourselves not everything in this world
should be your problem some things are
simply none of your
business focus on the issues that affect
you
directly you will be much happier that
way rejection is important important for
[Music]
self-development no one has the answer
you're going to spend a lot of time
figuring things
out most people stay in the same place
for a reason the things they hold dear
are the anchors that hold them in
place stop trying to make everyone love
you you need enemies to succeed
sometimes when you're in a dark place
you think you've been buried but
actually you've been
planted the person who cares less has
the most power in a
relationship never sacrifice your
progress for a friend they might not do
the same if the tables were
turned
the world doesn't care about your
potential it cares about what you've
done you spend all your health initially
for wealth and then you spend all your
wealth for one day of good
health never compare your life with
others they may seem better than you but
they have some problems which are never
ever heard by
you
don't tell anyone what you think or what
you know keep your secrets to
yourself because a friend of today could
be an enemy by
[Music]
tomorrow Embrace judgment no matter your
outcome you'll always be judged so don't
live to impress others live to impress
yourself worry is the ultimate bully
it takes everything and gives
nothing wasting time in regretting
cribbing and crying won't fetch you
results you are right about all the
things you think you need to do don't
wait get
started if something bothers you change
it if it is beyond your control learn to
to live with it accept it change
yourself that is the only thing you can
influence when you get up in the morning
remember what you promised yourself at
night you spend your first 20 years
worrying about what people think about
you you spend your next 20 years
swearing that you don't care what people
think about you you spend the next 20
years realizing that they aren't
thinking about
you to have what you never had you have
to do what you never
did people will say almost anything when
they're happy be wise and careful of
this
one the world will not treat you better
just because you're a good
person chasing the opposite sex and
having temporary
relationships which means nothing but
sex is
pointless what people say when they are
angry aren't things they mean they
regret it often forgive angry people
it's okay they are only
human the more people let you down the
easier you'll get back up and realize
that life doesn't stop for
anyone you can't litter negativity
everywhere and wonder why you have a
trashy
life not everyone will make it to your
future some people are passing through
to teach you life
lessons if you waste money you can earn
it again if if you miss the moment it
can never be
returned life isn't fair and sometimes
Good Deeds aren't rewarded and bad Deeds
aren't
punished things work out when you least
expect them life has a funny way of
surprising us when we're not looking for
it the ego is not a bad thing
and sometimes we need it in order to
achieve our aims and feel
Vitality however the ego is just a tool
we shouldn't let it control
us there will always be someone who is
better than you in something you have to
accept that fact and learn from them
that's something that will help you
grow betrayal never comes from your
enemies the hardest part is at the
beginning of the journey the rocket
loses 90% of its fuel during
takeoff a moment of patience in a moment
of anger saves from a thousand minutes
of
regret success is a loner's journey
you must learn to accept loss and make
compromises putting off until tomorrow
is your
weakness you can't always have a good
day but you can always face a bad day
with a good
attitude don't compare yourself to
others because no one can play Your Role
better than you
no work is beneath you the only thing
that should be beneath you is your big
ego work hard in silence and show your
skills at the job you get rather than
criticizing the
job no matter how hard you work you
can't have everything you want
eventually most of us end up settling in
some part of our life
owning your truth can be hard but not
nearly as hard as spending your life
running away from
it many of the people you told your
secret to have already told it to
others there is nothing more important
to true growth than realizing that you
are not the voice of the
mind you are the one who hears
it people only want to hear the good not
the bad so if you have issues it'll be
hard to find people to confide
in the walls you build to keep things
out are also keeping things
in there are times when you see someone
for the last time and don't even realize
it watch out you'll never know the true
value of the moment until it becomes a
memory never expect too high the more
you expect when it doesn't meet your
expectation the more it's going to
hurt you might regret your speech but
you'll never regret your
silence learn to let go even if you are
right life is a boxing game defeat is
not declared when you fall down it is
declared when you refuse to get
up it is indeed very hard to move on but
once you do you'll realize it was your
best
decision never make a promise you can't
keep stop letting other people take
advantage of you learn to say no and
understand your
rights saying no is
important people don't get offended as
much as you
think never awaken a woman's love with
no intention of loving
her
when talking to people look them in the
eye and on the face this will make you
more confident in front of
others find something you love something
you can lean on to something that would
keep you going you need something to
fall back on when you get
depressed nothing is
complicated not as much as you assume
it's just your mind playing tricks with
you if you get down to it it's all
really simple and
clear time is your most valuable
resource there are no refunds or second
chances for the time you
waste in order to love who you are you
cannot hate the experiences that shaped
you
be impatient with actions but patient
with
results if you're not happy with
yourself you'll never be happy in a
relationship being lonely and being
alone are different
things overthinking ruins you it ruins
the
situation twists things around makes you
worry about futile questions and makes
everything much worse than it actually
is most people are a complete waste of
time a lesson never ever goes away until
it has taught us what we need to
know don't let people know too much
about
you just trust your instincts gut
feelings can sometimes save you from big
troubles you don't get extra marks for
putting up with people you
dislike life is unfair don't moan don't
complain learn to be thick skinned make
the most of what you can
you don't have to be great to start but
to become great you just have to
start the moment poverty walks in
through the door love and peace toss
themselves out of the
window don't be emotionally attached to
anyone people change even your best
friends May probably turn into strangers
one
day no one cares except you do what
lifts you up in your eyes what people
say does not
matter think before you act you can take
a second to do something you haven't
properly
considered that isn't a true reflection
of your character and it can undo a
lifetime of kindness and gener
generosity life gives you lemons pepper
salt and sometimes cold water but they
don't come together or in a certain
order so keep struggling until the
lemonade is
ready if you can't do it now you won't
do it
ever regret won't change your past and
it will end up your future if you
continue to do
that don't make hopes hopes will create
expectation and expectation makes you
weaker some people just won't admit
they're wrong don't waste time trying to
get them to accept
it passion is super awesome but it
doesn't cure all your
problems passion can go a long way in
your life but it doesn't mean it's all
unicorns and
rainbows you are not unique there will
always be someone else equally
attractive fun and qualified to replace
you sometimes you just have to let
stupid people be
stupid
don't read a quote and say this is wise
but read a quote and say how can I
relate this to my
life